hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
very excited for this upcoming interview
uh for you to listen to it it was
totally full of joy today we have zarna
garg with us you might know her as a
comedian a tick-tocker a mother
a screenwriter she does it all her story
is incredible she
was from india she moved to the states
as a teen she was a stay-at-home mom
raising three kids in new york city
with a law degree under her belt for
years and then she found comedy and she
has been forging and creating her own
creative path in that world succeeding
and being hilarious the entire way she's
blown up on tick-tock her kids have
supported her she just has an incredible
story and she has some of the best
advice and perspective on the
entertainment industry on social media
on chasing your dreams i'm still
processing all of the wise words that
she shared and i hope you enjoy this
episode as much as i did not too deep
with zarna garg
[Music]
okay zarna i'm so excited to talk to you
uh thank you for being here first of all
and second of all
i want to know everything about you
can we can we kind of start uh back in
the beginning can you give me a little i
know you've probably told this story so
many times but can you give me a little
bit of your history
first of all namaste and thank you so
much for having me i'm so excited to be
here
and i have told the story many times but
never enough times to talk about myself
perfect i think i'm a perfect fit in the
world of entertainment i love talking
about myself oh great then this is going
to be an easy episode for me absolutely
that's the plan
uh so i'm an indian immigrant mom i have
three kids
uh and i'm married i have a husband
and a really really uh feisty
mother-in-law
i'm sure we'll hear more yes and you
might even hear from her she pops up
everywhere she's like a marvel super
villain she pops up everywhere
she could pop up in this window it
wouldn't shock me nothing shocks me
anymore
i can't wait
so i'm a stand-up comedian in new york
city
and a screenwriter
so okay so how did we get there uh
because i know that this has been quite
a journey for you and it's it's
so fascinating to me because you truly
have created your own path and i think
that is so inspiring and so i'm curious
how did we get into comedy how do we get
into entertainment because i know you
have a much more traditional background
and education
right i mean it's all it's a series of
accidents to be honest like not a single
indian woman that i i've ever thought of
dreamt of being a stand-up comedian wow
like had my parents been alive right now
they would be crying no doubt about it
they would be like we didn't get the
accountant we didn't get the dentist we
didn't have the doctor we got the funny
one how did this happen what did we do
wrong
they would be cursing of themselves
right now i mean oh my god you know but
this is life like i've been here in
america for over almost 30 years now
okay i went to college i went to law
school i'm licensed to practice in new
york city so very traditional in that
way
but for 16 years i was a stay-at-home
mom i had three kids in the city in new
york city with no help no family around
i couldn't do it all yeah you know i was
i couldn't figure out how to
be that person who could go to work and
rush home and put the dinner on that
like you know you see it all in movies i
just couldn't figure out how it's done
in real life like that's very relieving
to hear because i do think that it is
highly glamorized in a way that makes it
look effortless when it's truly not no
no no it first of all it is far from
effortless it's fueled by the
the drug industry that that that that
imagery is what is keeping you know the
major anti-depression yes medications in
business because
every mom and every woman out there is
thinking well she figured it out and the
truth is that none of us have figured it
out
you know because i i watched the same
movies that everybody else did i was
like how is it that
and you know and even when the actresses
are racing to get to pick the kid up and
put the food they look amazing yeah yeah
they put mascara on at some point no
they like somehow the hair is flowing
perfect and i can't get there even when
i have a glam teeth
so it you know i knew that something was
off and i really did try in the early
years but
it's really hard i mean the bottom line
is you can't have it all at the same
time that's my experience yeah but once
my little one was uh about to go to
school full time i was dying to make my
way back into the workforce and you know
do something
professional back again but even then
when you have young kids even if they're
in school the corporate life in america
is very unforgiving in my experience
things very well may have changed today
although you know how how fast do things
change i don't know
it was very complicated and i started
thinking what can i do
where can i position myself in a way
that
something that no one's doing right now
in america where the competition is a
little bit lighter and and i have an
interest and there's a need and you know
i grew up watching movies like everybody
else and i i was like why hasn't there
been a really fun indian rom-com
somehow indian movies in in the press
and in hollywood here are very heavy and
dark and they tackle
you know all the difficulties of being
indian or being asian and there's such a
fun site to us
that never makes it on screen so i
really i started tinkering in that space
and
really wrote a story straight out of my
heart without much expectations at all
wow
but that went on to win the austin film
festival top comedy feature award in
2019. so you okay so you see this need
you see this kind of unfulfilled area of
entertainment and you just decide to
write a story did you
have any experience with this so i took
a class
like not at the big university or
anything because god knows i was done
paying for the degrees in america that's
a whole another scam waiting to be
unraveled yeah i've spent so much money
getting my law degree and all that i was
like i am not going back to school i
could not afford it i would barely you
know
but there was one place i was teaching
you how to write screenplays like like a
three-month thing okay and then
literally google youtube like i just
went nuts i if i want to figure
something out if you want to figure
something out you can figure it out
today i i feel like that is the theme of
your entire career choices is that
you're just figuring it out as you go
but what else do you do you know what i
mean like you you if you wait for
somebody to tell you and teach you you
you're gonna die waiting i mean me i
would have just died who was gonna take
an indian mom seriously yeah
so i just you know i started poking and
took a few classes in the city and then
i i'm completely self-taught wow but you
know storytelling is storytelling
how you can write it and of course in
screenplay there are technical elements
and all but the heart of it all is
what's the story and are you able to
connect with the person who's reading it
or hearing it
and so was this rearranged that you
wrote okay
so you wrote rearranged and it won the
best comedy screenplay in the 2019
austin film festival that's right it's
incredible so what uh
how i mean that feeling must have been
wild
okay start dating i literally knew
nobody at the festival so i got the
award i took it to my hotel room and i
ordered a lunch for myself because i
literally didn't have anybody to talk to
that's i mean you and i are kindred
spirits i would have done the exact same
thing i don't know what else to do who
am i going to talk to i don't know
anybody but here's a message for women
for women of color for all of us and for
everybody who's not connected to things
i won the top prize at what i've been
told is the most prestigious festival
for writers for film writers
do you know how many agents and managers
wanted to talk to me after that
zero
wow
zero wow and i sat there with the thing
and i was like if i don't
keep
kicking down doors this will never get
made yeah like it is you would think you
know people are much more comfortable
with the known
and i was such an unknown like people
were very kind to me don't get me wrong
everybody was sweet hello how are you
you know congratulations when i was in
the room but beyond that they didn't
know what to do with me wow
and i didn't know anybody in the
business so i'm sitting here thinking i
won the thing why hasn't anybody called
me yet right right yeah and it's and
i've learned it's not that easy and uh
but
i don't give up that easily ask my
husband i'm still nagging him about
stuff from 20 like 20 2003
so i was thinking how do i get my voice
out there how do i show the world what
kind of things i want to talk about yeah
and you know my children are very
american they're born and raised in
manhattan
and my daughter off the cuff just said
why don't you just do stand-up comedy
mom you're so funny really and i was
like what are you talking about that
makes no sense who's gonna want to
listen to me and she's like mom my
friends love listening to you
because i'm constantly yelling at all
the kids about your grades and whatever
so she said to me do stand-up comedy and
that kind of triggered the first set of
like i wonder if
you know there is a space there and i
you know i kind of had to also when
you've yelled at your kids as much as i
have
when they tell you to do something you
better do it
yeah it's a it's a bit of a humbling
experience
they have some guidance for you of
course i was like what am i going to say
to her i'm too scared after telling her
for 15 years that she shouldn't be
scared yeah you know everything that i
would have said to her i had to say to
myself wow and i found an open mic and i
took that first step okay so talk to me
then about because just to
go from
you you get this success writing
something and then you enter into this
another unknown world of comedy when you
go to your first open mic what is that
experience like for you
so i honestly didn't even it didn't even
occur to me that stand-up comedy was a
job like
people did it for fun
you know and i grew up watching seinfeld
and ray romano and these people but i i
never thought that would be me
yeah you know you you know they're
standing there talking about like i
don't know new york city and all its
quirky stuff
and that seems so cool and like here i
am i'm a stay-at-home mom i've been
changing diapers for 15 years but what
am i gonna say that you know what i mean
yeah but i got up there
and i remember thinking wow white people
do this
like this is a job because it was an
open mic and a lot of people before me
had gone up and trashed the president
and
you know their jobs and their employ
like the thought of it is shocking to a
person from india yeah like it's so
heavily even though india is technically
a democracy
everything is so heavily like censored
you're scared
yeah you see something that's gonna
trigger somebody in the audience you're
gonna end up in jail like wow there's no
two ways about it so it
when i sat there i was just dumbfounded
that there was this whole world yeah of
people who were not afraid at all and
were actually being celebrated
so i got up on stage not knowing even
what a joke was
and the lady who was running it uh the
open mic said just talk about whatever
you think is funny yeah and i was like
okay so i got up and i started ranting
about my mother-in-law
the very first thing that comes to mind
yeah something must have happened that
day she must have sent some mean text or
something and i just like started
ranting and people were in splits they
were laughing so that's great so i got
off the stage and the woman said to me
you're very funny but you don't have
jokes
which i guess could seem harsh but i
mean well intentioned no no it was she
was completely right so i went home and
i did what i always do i googled what is
a joke
oh that's wonderful i was like oh so you
need a set up oh okay i get it and then
i started like
you know it's like like literally as if
i'm a nursery school kid learning abc
i i went from like level one to like you
know i started teaching myself and then
going more to open mics and leaning on
other comedians they've been so
welcoming to real comedy community i was
going to ask i know the new york city
especially comedy scene is it can be
very intense i was curious about your
experience there because it really does
feel like you have to
really put your
feet on the ground and like grind and go
to all of these open mics and try and
get as much stage time and experience as
you can
was that difficult or did you find it
exciting
so um
i'm not afraid of the grind at all i
mean you know listen
women first of all we expect it to be
hard
you know i don't expect anything to
happen easily it's just the default
setting is that i'm gonna have to fight
for it and work three times harder
mm-hmm
i mean right like you yeah
no 100 i feel like um um yeah it is such
a default setting that i forget that
sometimes i seem like a pessimist when
i'm really just a realist about
what's going on
yeah i mean listen when the rejections
pile up as they do for all of us
you know it you you have to be a little
more realistic it's just what it is even
if you're the biggest optimist yeah so i
completely expected it to be difficult
and you know at the stage i was at my
kids were in school
i was ready to work
i was ready to put in the time i i
wouldn't i wouldn't want it any other
way yeah i wasn't looking for an easy
way at all because i knew that i want to
build something that lasts
i wanted to learn every little nuance of
how things were done and where they were
done and
and i'm in it now and i love it like i
do five six seven shows a night
sometimes wow so you're really in it
right now i'm all in well you're also
are you preparing you have like a full
hour that you're preparing right yes
that's right okay so talk me through how
do you how do you get this material how
do you create your full hour
so um
the
the joke started coming easily once i
understood what a joke format was right
once i knew okay what are they talking
about i got it because i had the
material right yeah it's just the
formula yeah my whole life i've been
saying things but okay there is a rhythm
to how you do it yeah it's a similar in
some ways to screenwriting once i
understood okay got it this is act one
and then you start it's a little more
organized but it's still storytelling
it's still interesting storytelling so
the jokes came but then what i started
doing is i started watching every other
stand-up special that's out there yeah
like how have other people done it like
what is the crux of what makes that
special special
and it started like it started making
sense to me and i do a lot of analysis
like all comedians do we record most of
our sets i go home i go why did they
laugh here what is enjoying more and
started building like a flow
around that you know so for i think in
my case
people like to enjoy the
happy family stories you know the me
yelling at my kids i mean it's it's
those happy family stories yeah yeah you
didn't get it 98 whatever stop being
stop celebrating where are you
yeah so they they enjoy the
mother-in-law sub they enjoy the india
america life comparisons like how it
would have been that was a big
motivation of mine to get on stage too
by the way it's like i
watched the last few years people in
america
really hard on themselves
about oh this country everybody's
laughing at us and we're so bad and
we're i just needed i felt like somebody
needed to remind them that people like
me give up everything to come here
because it's great yeah yeah with all
its problems it's great here just
perspective yeah
so i i felt like i was in a position to
offer some relief
to the general american audience that
was so hard on themselves um like how
can you otherwise as an american say
that to yourself you can't you need that
outsider to remind you yeah and i was
happy to be that outsider i mean living
here gave me an amazing life i felt like
i could give something back
at a moment that
people needed it wow i mean there's
that's very beautiful that you have
almost a humanitarian mission to make
everyone feel a little bit better
i mean it's crazy but i really do like
if you come to any of my shows yeah the
way every show is designed
my audience here has to leave elated
that's beautiful
because it's what i believe it's what i
it's what i've experienced of my life
here and i want to share it the truth of
my journey like for example winning a an
award like austin film festival would
not happen back home even for me yeah
there's no such competition the only
movies that get made are movies written
by friends of existing movie makers or
kids or so
i have no problem acknowledging that
this system has been so wonderful to me
and uh and that's part of the whole set
planning too like you know i i and and
you know this doesn't mean i don't poke
funds i think that pokemon you know we
do weird things here yeah and there are
weird things that i that happened back
where i came from in india too
yeah but it's all
the base of it is a lot of love
yeah i mean you have a it feels like you
bring the maternal energy with you and
sort of nurture an audience in a way
oh my god i want to yell at everybody
but you know you know the clubs love to
push the drinks the two drinks yeah yeah
i'm
like i one day will get banned from all
the clubs because i'm the first one to
be like drink water
no two drinks can be any two drinks
give yourselves
yeah i know you're giving them uh the
golden ticket to not paying 40 extra
dollars yeah i'm such a mom that i can't
help but be like it's okay you can get
the second one get me water
i see that's great it's showing true
signs of care for the people that are
coming out to see you so how are you
feeling about this hour now
i'm feeling great yeah i'm feeling
amazing yes it's like you know it's a
lot uh
there are days when i get completely
overwhelmed when what am i doing like
you know i can't believe
what is all happening but surreal but
you know
most days i treat a show or a
preparation as if i'm hosting a party
with my friends um
and then that
relaxes the whole thing that i've done
my whole life
my whole life people have come to my
home or i've gone to their homes and
i've made them laugh or whatever yeah i
can do this i have to say to myself and
also as a woman once again
we tend to second-guess ourselves a lot
more than men do
and because i'm aware of it i want to
become a voice against it
of course i get scared and i get nervous
but like so many of us do and we lose
out on big opportunities yeah and and
it's time to like take ownership of that
flaw and like reverse it a little bit
i mean i'm getting inspired just sitting
here talking to her like taking notes
i'm like do not second
guess so now we're going to take a quick
break when we get back i have to ask you
all about now the flourishing tick tock
side of things yes absolutely we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you
and uh second thing if you are enjoying
yourself here in this not too deep world
we've built and you'd like to leave us
review that would be so wonderful if you
can go to the itunes store the app store
and leave us a lovely little review
comment how are you feeling good bad
otherwise maybe just good or otherwise
would be appreciated other than that
enjoy the podcast
okay zarna we're back in now i gotta i i
read some interviews with you and so i
kind of know about your um tick tock
side of things but how do you explain
how this got going again another happy
accident and having kids who work for
you yeah oh so they officially work for
you your kids
well officially especially
i hesitate to say officially because
then they're gonna start being like
where's the paycheck right right right
i'm like do you have an official payroll
for all of them
not yet not yet but they do eat well so
there's like oh there you go um no they
they do help me a lot to be honest and
you know again the i just got the comedy
thing going in 2019 it was just going i
got my first show
and then boom
the world shut down
i was like this is i really thought that
the hindu gods were against me yeah i
feel like like this is crazy we don't
need her out there
every time you get a win they put you
back in your place right and you know my
mother-in-law has
prayed her whole life i was like this is
her this has to be her
i was never the praying type so i was
like this all makes sense yeah
i was sitting in my you know in my house
thinking it's over like i i don't know
how i'm gonna recover from an unending
what at the time we were like we're not
sure when yeah and the clubs closed like
they closed down and that's yeah that's
your life force that's exactly
so um and my son my 15 year old son
said to me you know mom he's a tick-tock
paddock yeah
i mean he watches he's just watching he
doesn't really post much yet
and he's like you know i'm starting to
see comedians
and you know at the time when tiktok was
brand new newish to me at least a year
or two years ago it felt like it was
just young girls dancing yes same to me
i have um still not figured it out so
i'm kind of gleaning all of your
personal tips and tricks on it because
it does feel very overwhelming to me it
felt like what am i gonna do there yeah
you know what i mean like if you're not
16 or 15 even you're too old for that
yeah they're gonna bounce you out of the
club right but he showed me so he was
like you know he was
trying to explain to me that i should
get on and i kept ignoring him because i
was like oh god no go away you know
i try not to listen to my kids that's
the rule
the number one rule of parenting is
don't listen to your kids like whatever
they want do the opposite yeah yeah yeah
so i was like showing him away and he
just took a few of my jokes
that i had on tape and edited them and
put them on an account for me wow
and you know
within three days i think we had a
million views wow and then i started
thinking is ticktock one of those weird
places you know some countries they have
the currencies that start at a million
dollars yes you don't really know what
it's worth yeah yeah yeah
maybe tick tock is one of these weird
places where like if you if you just
wave your hand you get a million views
yeah yeah that's the that's the base
level yeah because you don't know right
right you don't know what you don't know
but then once i started engaging with it
a little bit i realized that it is
actually
honestly tick-tock is a magical place
for creators yeah yeah so i mean first
of all it's incredible because it sounds
like your children truly believe in you
which is very beautiful
oh they're very scared of me
or they just want you to get a hobby and
leave them yeah
i think that's more like it
and second of all i'm so now it's been
like uh over a year or so on this
platform yeah what how's the experience
been for you like do you
prefer tick-tock over live performance
or is it two different things for you
it's two different things and i i think
in the world that we're in today
unfortunately or fortunately both need
to coexist yeah yeah i don't think you
can be a live performer without having a
social media following very true and if
you
although i do think there are digital
performers who never do anything live
and make a killing yeah i've heard about
them
but i i've never considered that path
because i actually like
traditional stand-up comedy yeah so i
just don't think you could do anything
today without having a social media
following and tick-tock is is
amazing to creators it's head and
shoulders above all other creators
because of their magical for you page
it really does put you in front of so
many different types of audiences yeah
until you find your own
yeah that's very true i haven't thought
about it that way exactly
because i don't think i mean i think
instagram for example has an explorer
page it's just not even in the league of
what tick-tock does yeah i mean
tick-tock is very kind of
singular where you can see one video at
a time versus instagram is like here's
this magic eye of a bunch of little
videos that you can look at and click on
and see and then no video gets attention
you know because there are 20 things on
the screen
yeah no one gets that kind of attention
so now i'm curious with your children
helping you kind of initiate your tic
tac uh uh
you know
iconery
do you work with them on creative ideas
on tick tock do they come and pitch you
ideas
all the time and honestly sometimes
we'll have a funny moment
or a moment that actually is not funny
at all
but they'll be like you know what mom i
bet you if you put this on tick-tock
that people will be interested
because
a lot of what i do is everyday mom life
like i don't particularly find it that
interesting it's just how we live yeah
but it never occurred to me that that
putting that out there gives other
people a chance to resonate with it
for example my best performing tech talk
right now is a video of us traveling
and my luggage being overstuffed it was
way over 50 pounds yeah
now have i traveled like this most of my
life yes
yeah
most of my life the last minute i need
to take five pounds yeah that's
overweight or am i gonna pay the fee or
what what are we gonna do yeah you know
but now when a moment like that happens
and my kid will be like
let's just capture mom taking stuff out
of their bed
i feel like you're on constant
surveillance now with your family of
everything you do
but you know honestly i i don't have a
problem with it i'm just living my life
and yeah and if other people are finding
so many commonalities
and connecting with me i'm like fine go
do it and literally that's how a lot of
our tick tocks have generated they're
real genuine moments yeah i'm curious
about the messages that you receive or
the comments that you get or
um you know the people that are
following you or the people that order
cameos from you like uh what's that
is the majority of it like moms that
feel very connected to you
or is it started out it started out as
mom's and the mom community and then it
became the teenagers who saw their mom
in me yeah yeah
and then once my i love i've never said
i love you videos started getting
getting traction it just became people
from all over the world who said well
you don't say it either
you know i mean
when we put when i put that that was one
of my first jokes up there i've never
said i love you to my husband and that's
true yeah and uh
you know i thought it was just me
i really thought that it's an indian
thing at best
but the minute that joke got on tick
tock i can't tell you people from
different cultures across sections all
over we don't say neither here is it
just a hollywood thing is it an
entertainment thing is it a white people
thing yeah is it an affluent no i mean
now they're debates if you go through my
tick tock there are lively debates over
this over the importance of using the
word love wow so it kind of grew from
the mom community and kind of just
fanned out into all kinds of different
things oh wow that's i mean it's very
it's got to be for you at least
feeling less alone in the things that
you once thought were only you and also
getting to start this uh kind of healthy
debate between everyone i think is is
the best kind of situation i mean i'll
tell you that i got a lot of comfort
from knowing that people who've been
discouraged especially i get a lot of
singles too by the way i have no idea
why i'm not a matchmaker but a ton of
single people when i do lives singles
pop up hey auntie do you match me why am
i not able to find a girl or a guy or
whatever wow i'll tell you that the one
thing that i i have
i feel blessed about is that a lot of
single uh women in particular will say
to me
thank you for telling the truth about
married life
wow
this big romantic you know because yeah
the imagery and the stories that exist
in pop culture are so over the top
can you buy your rose and the ring and
all like and that stuff is just not part
of our culture at all
we're just happy to pay our bills
together
we're so happy if we can pay our bills
at the end of the month and if
everybody's alive and healthy
no it's a win
that is i mean that is romance right
there but still i think so i i think i
get a lot of guys that like laugh about
how i brought the nerdy guy back because
like my husband's just
he's just a regular really good guy
sitting there obsessing about like where
he should take me for dinner and like
what is all that i know you know so i i
i feel happy that i'm able to reassure
some young couples or some single people
that you don't need to have all that
yeah to have a good family life it is
very reassuring and you are telling the
truth and not and you're not going out
of your way to tell the truth you're
just going like here
this is great that everybody has in
their life their moms or dads their
uncles or aunts are living very simple
basic lives and i think that that life
should be celebrated yeah i agree
[Music]
i'm gonna move on to ask you the two
questions i ask every single guest that
is on the podcast with me the first is
who alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti at
wow golden spaghetti
i have to i have to be honest right kind
of
my mother-in-law
i mean
yeah there are a lot of wounds in here
that we won't get into because that's a
whole like episode season yeah
but i think that
i think that the cold spaghetti would be
the appropriate level of violence back
for the emotional trauma that i had to
endure
you know what that is um i'm gonna take
you at your word for that
okay the other question i ask every
single guest
um is to tell us
your worst pant [ __ ] story or like a
a bathroom emergency situation
but
you can only use three words or small
phrases to describe the situation so for
example my story uh is college jogging
front lawn
ah
okay wow
so the listener is imagining is
connected they get to create the own
their own imagery in their heads
okay so i i have one it's right it's
like right there because it's real great
so uh
[Music]
staining due to a very heavy period okay
yep
about to go on stage
oh no
and lights all around me oh
god yeah
that one
hits me in my gut that one it
paints a picture for everyone
um okay now we're gonna move on to a
section of the podcast called deep and
hot where i ask you a deep question that
we have prepared for you and then i'm
going to ask you for your hot take on
kind of like a subject matter that we
have prepared for you so
the deep question is what does it mean
to be zarna
um
donna is a storyteller um
yeah she's an authentic real
indian woman storyteller wow it's
beautiful
yeah well with that too i want to go
back and ask you before i get into the
hot take about auntie z
yeah can you tell us a little bit about
this
yeah it's just you know i've become like
some sort
of
general community auntie to everybody
yeah look you know the people who reach
out to me the young ones you know the
singles the young people the teens they
i'm not their mom i'm not there you know
yeah but in indian culture
pretty much everybody who's not your mom
or your brother or sister is your auntie
or uncle okay so it's very common to
refer to somebody else slightly older
than you as an auntie or uncle i see and
you also have a show concept that you're
kind of creating around this yes
and
can is it be you're being you're
pitching it you're developing it
so it's actually in in negotiation right
now it's already past the stage of
pitching oh that's amazing
congratulations okay we're sending good
energy positive energy manifesting all
of the good stuff for it i think the
world needs it and wants it right a lot
of people waiting to be yelled at
yeah that's true in a sweet nurturing
way
okay with that this kind of goes in line
um i'm curious about your hot take and
you've already sort of talked about this
or any like tips that you have or pieces
of advice
wisdom if you will on on creating your
own path or forging your own path
because i feel like you've
become almost an expert at this and i
know it's unique to every individual but
i'm curious if you have any advice on it
yeah i'll tell you what gives me courage
because i get scared just like everybody
else right folding your own path by by
definition is scary because it's
untested
there's no road map
i had a moment
of re one day before stand up i was like
what am i doing i had a moment and then
i realized i'm like if i want to do
something
i'm gonna have to figure it out nobody
on earth can figure it out for me yeah
even with the best intentions nobody can
step in and say here let me hold your
hand and show you the best way to do it
and you will for sure get rave reviews
and you will succeed that is just not
how life works
so once i had this deep realization that
it's all on me
i just went for it and the other thing
that has given me a huge amount of
relief and i think all your listeners
can take comfort from
we live in a self-obsessed generation
and time yeah would you agree with that
very much people are very obsessed with
your own images and the beauty plus and
the upload and the download of their own
life
there's something extremely liberating
about it
for for a creator
whatever i create is just not big enough
on anybody's spectrum to last more than
a second yeah
you know you could kill somebody and
people are gonna forget in a minute yeah
that's pretty true so as a creator it's
it's a way to take the pressure off of
you you're just one spec and the upside
of it is so big
let's say you are good yeah and you're
able to make somebody laugh or cry or
feel with whatever it is that you're
creating
you put something so good out into the
world
that may positively affect so the
downside is so small let's say you fail
spectacularly yeah
that show that you know the the event
that you talked about the three part you
know the the bleeding this that actually
really happened right but who remembers
it no one
life went on everything went on
and i think we should all take comfort
from the fact that this self-obsessed
generation is so
busy
finally filtering their own photos they
don't have time just to pick on you wow
that's a incred my mind's a bit blown
right now and i'll have to continue to
process that throughout the day because
i think that's such a wonderful
perspective on that because i think
people can get so overwhelmed by feeling
like they have nothing to contribute to
such an oversaturated environment online
what could they possibly how they have
to make the best possible thing to stand
out and that's not necessarily a healthy
way to view that
not at all and in fact to respond to the
don't have anything to contribute i
offer to my followers all the time
because i get that too i don't know what
to do i don't know where to start
if you do nothing
if you create nothing you make nothing
the easiest way to add a positive
contribution to our world right now is
to just go on other people's pages who
you like
and give them positive reinforcement oh
that's i tell my followers i'm like
sprinkle positivity like confetti what
doesn't cost you nothing yeah and the
more you put it out there trust and
believe that the more will come back to
you wow
well i feel like you need to write some
sort of life coaching manual as well
along with all your other projects going
on um zarna this has been so lovely
we're uh towards the end of the podcast
but before we wrap up completely we like
to give our guests a little token of our
appreciation and that is a personalized
horoscope from us to you um we are not
astrologists by any means melissa put it
in the chat if you're able to access
that and if you would like to read it
aloud to the class yeah so it's it says
it's for pisces i think right yes okay
so should i just read it out yes dear
pisces fish of the stars you'll feel
pressure when mars and your ruling
planet neptune connect this month to
have a real plan for your dream bowls by
the 11th but you'll have to choose
between the rest of your kids getting
into iv ivy schools and six seasons of
rtz
just kidding you can have it all hello
there it is thank you of course now uh
this has been so lovely thank you so
much for your time and your wisdom more
importantly where can people find you
online where they where can they come
see you live if they don't know
they can find me at zanagar.com at
zarnagarg on all major platforms
instagram tick tock twitter
uh facebook you name it and i have a
show schedule that's posted on my
website okay so at zanagar.com shows you
can see all my upcoming shows i have a
big show coming up at caroline's on
broadway on february 4th where i'm
headlining i'm running my full hour for
two shows
and i'm gonna be at the kennedy center
on march 18th and 19th opening for uh
persian american comedian mars giobrani
amazing yeah so i'm gonna be there so we
have a lot come going i'm gonna be in
las vegas in february for a week
you're all over the place i'm all over
the place because i gotta find every
location i can to trash my mother-in-law
you gotta spread it far and wide well
thank you so much zarna this has been
such a delight uh and go check out
everything she's up to you'll find her
somewhere she's in all the nooks and
crannies of the internet and the real
world and we'll see you guys next time
on another episode of not too deep
goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music